[موسيقى]
نور الاحتجاجاتي لا تخمد خناق يلف مدن
ايران
ينتفضوا اهلها على باب رزقهم حتى اغلاقات
لا تردد فيها لاحياء ذكرى قتل النظام
الايراني للمتظاهرين عام 2019
اصحاب المحل التجاريه والباعه في اسواق
ايران يقولون كلمتهم اضرابات عن العمل في
عده مدن ايرانيه دعما ايضا لمظاهرات خرجت
منذ شهرين لاسقاط النظام هكذا هو الحال
ملامح العصيان على اوجه المحلات في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه انضموا جميعهم الى دعوات
لمسيرات الاحتجاج العام لا شيء يوقفهم رغم
تهديدات النظام الايراني بتوسيع رقعه
الاعتقالات والاعدامات بين صفوف المحتاجين
كارثه وجوديه تواجه الشباب والقصر في
ايران بسبب الاعتقالات الاخيره بحسب وصف
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اكدت في تقريرها
الاخير عن اعتقاله ايران للمئات من
المشاركين في المظاهرات وقتل الكثيرين في
حمله قمع وحشيه تشنها السلطات واشارت
الصحيفه الى ان استهدف الشباب ياتي وسط
حمله قمع للمحتجين تخللها اعتقاله
14,000 شخص اضافه الى استهداف للاطفال
وقتلي خمسين قاصرا على الاقل حتى الان
تهديد ووعيد من السلطات الايرانيه بحده
غير مسبقه على مدى العقدين الماضيين بحسب
التقرير ايضا ما ينظر بمستقبل انساني يشتد
ضبابيه اكثر فاكثر غذاء سالم العربي